il est trop tôt il fait beaucoup trop
chaud gdgt kaka au coin des yeux
d'ailleurs je vous ferai peut-être un
épisode jours pour vous raconter
programme ducalcon aux yeux mais c'est
le jour où je dois aller me faire passer
de cyril au au laser donc je prends ma
douche et je vous reprends après on y va
c'est reparti fait bizarre parce que la
dernière le dernier rendez vous c'était
il ya un mois on s'était habitué à deux
mois d'intervalle chez un patient cet
égard
[Musique]
bonjour
on a mis la pommade anesthésiant donc
regardeur humeur que s'est agi salon
enfin seul là
j'ai pris de communiqué
e
restez bien intéressant dont la tête en
parler là je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
alors qu'en fait
voilà c'est fait une de plus de moins ne
s'est encore pas trop mal passé au
niveau douleur je rentre chez moi on en
discute et voilà bon je suis installé
sur mon lit parce que c'est là qu'il
fait plus frais et puis je suis plus à
mon aise et donc c'est pas moi qui ai
choisi lepage et par locataire allons
aller plus loin on va sur un petit point
fesses alors voilà à quoi ressemblait la
bête ce matin avant la serbie s'est pas
flagrant flagrant en photo mais ça c'est
un petit peu éclairci par les traits se
sont un peu atténuées surtout à certains
endroits donc c'est plutôt bon signe
même si j'ai pas encore le cul senti
d'errance un comique est aussi alors il
ya cette petite particularité que vous
aurez noté au niveau des yeux savoir que
les deux dernières séances avec l'ancien
laser le médecin avec bien bien ont
tabassé à cet endroit là du coup je
pense que la peau à un petit peu
souffert j'arrive pas à savoir si en
dessous lancre a disparu si c'est juste
cette espèce de pot bizarre qui donne
cette impression là en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que là pour est beaucoup
plus fragile est beaucoup plus sensible
à ce à septembre là et que j'ai tendance
à bloquer
par contre ce qui est sûr et ça c'est
vraiment une bonne nouvelle c'est que
définitivement ça fait beaucoup moins
mal qu'avant et pourtant évidemment
médecins avaient augmenté la puissance
d'un cran par rapport au rendez vous
précédents la douleur à vous avez
commencé
ok j'en rajoute un peu parce qu'on sent
quand même un par endroits mais vraiment
c'est sans comparaison par rapport aux
premières séances grâce à la pommade
anesthésiante je vous en ai parlé à dire
la fois d'ailleurs pas mal de questions
à ce sujet là donc cette pommade
en fait c'est elle contient des produits
qui sont les mêmes que ceux qu'on
utilise pour les anesthésies locales
sauf que là bas voilà ça se met en
couche épaisse sur la zone qu'on veut
qu'on voudrait sensibiliser
ensuite on referme avec un pansement qui
bien qu'il doit être bien étanche
on laisse mariner pendant pendant une
heure et ensuite la peau est endormi
pendant une à deux heures et ça marche
vraiment bien
donc si vous devez vous faire détatouer
un jour vraiment insister pour avoir ma
peau manade la peau mate de ce type là
parce que vraiment il n'y avait aucune
gloire à tirer de d'avoir mal quand on
peut éviter de souffrir
donc comme un anesthésiant c'est une
tomate qu'on trouve en pharmacie c'est
sur ordonnance 1 en général on s'en sert
pour par exemple des prises de sang un
peu douloureuse donc la façon dont ça se
passe dans le cadre du des tatouages
le médecin vous fait une ordonnance vous
allez chercher la pommade à la pharmacie
vous vous la mettez
sur la zone à des tatoués donc une heure
avant votre rendez vous fermez bien le
pansement et puis vous allez vous allez
sur place moi dans mon cas étant donné
l'emplacement du tatouage c'est un peu
trop acrobatique pour que je la mette
tout seul donc il me la mettre sur place
et j'attends les normes
quand vous allez je trouve à m'occuper
alors quelques années par les pansements
les p'tits pansements transparent qu'on
met sur la sur la peau mate s'est
vraiment passé en place m si ce n'est au
niveau de la fesse ah oui alors autre
nouveauté le médecin appelle mon
tatouage cyril et plus capitaine haddock
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup
bon et maintenant ben le petit tour
traditionnel art je sais que je sais que
vous attendez ça alors ça vous l'avez
déjà vu c'est avant de partir au rendez
vous ce matin dix danseurs il faudra
faire un petit pull in sur le nez là non
ça c'était en enlevant le pansement
juste après la séance
là c'est le lendemain les trucs autour
on dirait vraiment des hématomes jeu au
prochain rendez vous je demande aux
médecins si c'est bien ça et si c'est
normal
là c'est deux jours après c'est à ces
trois jours plus tard et ça c'est quatre
jours plus tard évidemment pour être sûr
qu'ils se passe quelque chose je vous
donne rendez-vous dans un mois on parce
qu'il faut le temps que tout sa façon
petit ouvrage
oui un mois parce que donc vous rappeler
c'est plus tous les deux mois avant
danser tous les mois comme j'ai dit au
début de la vidéo
du coup bas mes fesses ça va être votre
votre petite série estivale votre votre
saga de l'été comme comme zodiac mais en
plus polis
et du coup d'essai c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour des nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là je vous souhaite un bel été
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]